there's these two competing spheres of
power
and unfortunately the authoritarian
communist model of china is
is rapidly growing and if they ever take
over taiwan
yeah that will be a disaster i think do
you i think that'll happen under joe
biden do you think so
uh well so then we should be talking
about like uh
kirk campbell and jake sullivan like
people who might be um
working for the uh biden administration
some of the things they've said and it
does seem
what are some examples and who are these
people okay so uh jake sullivan
was um the national security adviser to
vice president biden
biden wants him as the national security
adviser
and he talked about how um like he
considers uh
china's rise like one of his great
successes he was working for that
and he and kirk sullivan kirk campbell
uh penned an editorial in foreign
affairs where they
they talk about um well like
keeping the status quo with taiwan for
instance
and china has promised to invade taiwan
yeah
are they they're doing beaching drills
yeah and they uh normally like
every year there's like this message
about peaceful reunification they
removed peaceful this year
violent communication so you know what
happens when the status quo is changed
by the chinese communist party invading
taiwan what are the what are they going
to say about that
kirk campbell yeah kirk campbell was
also behind one of the biggest foreign
policy failures of the u.s since like
the fall of saigon with the
scarborough shoal incident in 2002 2012.
what was that
so the scarborough shoal we actually
went there
we'll see we can tell that story later
um it's like this uh this reef kind of
near the philippines it's very important
to local filipino fishermen
um it's in the south china sea and
originally it was kind of a place where
filipino fishermen and vietnamese
fishermen chinese fishermen they could
all go and fish in the place
it was claimed by several different
countries including the philippines and
china
yeah but then in 2012 china sends in its
uh coast guard and basically occupies
the shoal um kirk campbell leads the u.s
delegation to because the philippines
are a treaty ally
with the u.s uh we have a mutual defense
pack with them so
this might trigger that right that they
came in and they come to blows it looked
like they were going to come to blows
whoa and so they they they work out this
deal where you know the chinese will
leave and the philippine side will leave
and that'll be fine well the philippine
forces leave
the chinese forces stay yeah and the us
did nothing under trump no this was
under this 2012 under obama oh that's
right wow
and this sent shock waves throughout the
asia pacific because suddenly this was
like all of these other countries
realizing
if the us will turn its back on a mutual
defense ally what's going to happen to
us
we so thailand began moving closer to
the chinese communist party
uh philippines south korea we also
lost south korea when um we were putting
in the thaad missile defense system
and china freaked out about that and
began a huge economic warfare against
south korea
no support from the us i was out we were
both the luke and i were in south korea
and there were people protesting
the the thaad defense system yeah i mean
it was controversial within south korea
that is true
that is definitely true but so this was
like devastating for the image of the
u.s
uh all throughout the years that was
obama that was under obama and
specifically this agreement was
negotiated by
for a guy who loved war you think he'd
have done something
i mean supposedly i mean supposedly
somebody said we're not going to go to
war over a bunch of rocks
was that kirk it might have been i think
it was him that's insane
so but like the wider geopolitical
effect it has disastrous for the u.s it
was terrible and it allowed china to
basically have free reign within the
south china sea in general i don't think
they were prepared for that i think that
totally rewrote
their their their timeline of what they
could do things because after that
that's when you see them really building
up
artificial islands and militarizing
these are tolls right they've like these
these are yes and stuff
because now they have like
missiles on them yeah and when the u.s
says hey don't build those missiles
what do you think china is going to do
well do you
remember recently when they did the
elephant march i think it's called in
guam
elephant march yeah so uh when the
strike group from china went through
the that straight between taiwan and
what's it called the taiwan street
taiwan straight i guess uh trump had
deployed bombers and and heavy military
forces to an air base in guam and then
they did i guess what's called an
elephant walk or something
where you see all of these war you know
planes going you know
around showing them look what we got
ready to go
and then we were treated because the us
military found out that china has
weapons capable of wiping out the entire
air base before those planes can get off
the ground
so we were forced to pull back and
retreat well that also reminds me of
that the chinese navy has more ships
than the u.s now which are not
necessarily the same
equivalent in terms of technical
capability yeah
but the us military has just been so
focused on the sandbox
yeah and not on china i'll tell you
not that it's a one-for-one comparison
or a comparison at all
but i think most people who play
strategy games know the power
of a wave of small
troops versus one powerful unit so
we often hear from the from the the u.s
uh gun control advocates when they say
what you think you're going to go to war
against the american government they
have
cruise missiles and the typical response
is
if you think uh if if that's what you
think you need to look up the history of
vietnam and afghanistan
a handful of people with weapons is is
going to outdo you know it's going to
easily i'll put it this way
fighter jets can't occupy street corners
so there is something to be said for
china having more
ships even if they're not nearly as
capable because uh
you know and and correct me if i'm wrong
i don't think you guys are experts on
you know world war ii in russia but i
was reading about how
russia mass produced really low quality
tanks
that were getting blown up like crazy by
the nazis but they just had so many
just can't wave after wave of our own
men that's kind of the ak strategy right
the what strategy the the ak-47 just
like
ease like yup simple gun versus like the
m
what was the m6 they like bro had all
kinds of issues they could
said you could bury in the mud and still
use it make something that
is cheap but easy to produce and fast
and then sure the nazis were able to
blow up these russian tanks but they
just kept sending wave after wave
because they could just keep making them
well that's
zach brannigan's strategy exactly wave
after wave of our own men
until we run out of bullets we have to
understand when we look at china's
strategy now it's it's
pretty pretty brilliant i mean
historically china hasn't been that
strong because of its geopolitical
location
but if they're able to offset the fight
on islands especially along very
important trade routes
they're implementing a similar policy
like the japanese did during world war
ii they don't want the fight in tokyo
they want the fight in the pacific
so this is the first beginning of this
chinese expansion which they need
because essentially they're landlocked
and they're landlocked in not a strong
position
when you look at their natural resources
they're not doing that well as you said
they just
imported a whole bunch of grain because
it's very hard for the chinese
government
and the chinese country to produce for
itself this is why they're also trying
to expand their territory
in the himalayas against the troops in
india so
we're seeing if china really wants to
dominate the world they're going to have
to have a bunch of islands
along these trade routes and if you look
at world wars
they always start along trade routes so
this is
very key and and one of the reasons why
they're building so many of these
uh strategic locations that they're
expanding it so we have to
keep it yeah five trillion dollars of
shipping goes through the south china
sea yes
yes and so they need that seaport
control yes that's why it's so important
to them
and the reason why they're putting the
uyghur muslims in these camps is because
they need total social control
people who adhere to a religion have a
higher power
they need to be the power weren't they
replacing image like religious images
with like chairman mao
yeah definitely i mean that's been going
on for a while yeah well also mal
it's the same strategy they've actually
been using all throughout uh
70 years of the chinese communist party
history like everything that's happening
in xinjiang now uh to a lesser extent
they did to the falun gong practitioners
before that
and we were just talking to somebody
from southern mongolia
uh which is inner which is in here
mongolia they did the same wave of
genocide in mongolia that
people don't really hear about they did
it in tibet these these are all the same
things just the same strategies just
being refined and refined
and we just don't stop i'll tell you
something crazy uh
there was a period where just i'll just
say some someone that i know
very well would make you was it was a
youtuber
and they got an email one day from
someone who asked them to upload
a video to their youtube channel not to
run an ad not to do a promo to straight
hey would you
would you be willing to upload a video
to your channel in exchange for 200
the video was some guy in new york
talking about falun gong
and how backwards it was but it was a
really interesting bit of propaganda
where the person wasn't saying falun
gong is bad they were like
it's so strange that we we allow this
weird
cult-like religion in our country why
would we do this
you know we have these people and
they're dangerous and it's like a
really i really i said i said don't
upload that don't take the money but
people did
so so they found channels that were
small to mid size maybe 10
20 000 subscribers or more would just be
like wow a couple hundred bucks i need
the money and they would upload this
propaganda piece from china
wow yeah it's it's amazing like all the
little pieces of propaganda that
are able to filter into the yeah can you
guys explain some of the larger
propaganda efforts that are utilized
in china i know there's a crackdown on
religions but
are i also have seen videos of people
rebelling and fighting against the the
chinese government as well
is there anything legitimately going on
or is the propaganda so strong with the
social credit score that there isn't any
resistance at all
oh okay um here's here's an interesting
story that kind of ties
ties into that um though
it might seem tangential uh there was a
story uh this past year of
uh a chinese student who was studying in
the us he
did a he made a post to twitter in the
u.s
comparing chinese chairman xi jinping to
the villain from biker mice from mars
okay and then he goes back to china and
is arrested
for that so the
the first and biggest victims of the
chinese communist party's actions are
always
the chinese people themselves yeah um
now i think you should tell the story
about uh chen guangcheng what he told
you
oh yeah we um chugwan chen is a blind
chinese human rights act he's the
daredevil he's the uh he was a
he was a barefoot lawyer in china and he
was
arrested for basically trying to help
women who had had forced abortions
because of the one child policy and he
was just trying to help them
get some kind of like legal redress
china is anti-choice and anti-life
yeah yeah just both and then uh
he was put in prison for years for you
know traffic violations
um and then he was put under house
arrest for many years too but he managed
to
escape house arrest and
uh make his way to beijing we had
activists helping him and he made made
it to the u.s embassy
wow uh back in 2012 and the us ended up
granting him asylum oh wow um so we
interviewed him last year
and he was talking about how you know it
looks from the surface to a lot of
people like the chinese people as a
whole support the chinese communist
party
especially because a lot of the chinese
nationals that you'll meet in places
like the us they're
rich and they're rich because their
families have some connection to the
party
or their families are party members like
they have
some kind of wealth that's tied back to
the communist party so
you know and also all the young people
have been kind of brainwashed
uh to be very nationalistic uh so
they'll be very supportive of the
chinese communist party but that's not
the real case on the ground but you
can't know that because even on the
internet
chinese people are very careful about
what they say because they know that
you're going to get sent to prison for
you know saying the wrong thing on
wechat or whatever so they won't say it
online they're they're videos i've seen
where you know somebody might be filming
in china
and then they ask a question the person
will like go under their breath and be
like i don't know i can't talk about
that yeah
and so yeah that's so he was saying that
there are people there are so many
people who are against the chinese
communist party
but it is hard unless you have the
connections inside china to know that
they're there
i want to point something out real quick
too uh because there's a stereotype
about chinese people being really bad
drivers
right you've probably heard it the
family guy is a joke where you know just
the other day we're watching family guy
there's a chinese woman and she's like
how many how long do i need a signal to
change eight lanes and then she just
crashes the car or whatever
but uh i was talking to uh this guy you
know who who spent a lot of time
a lot of a lot of his life in china and
he said what people don't realize
the chinese who can make it to the
united states tend to be wealthier than
those who are
who stay in china it's only possible and
many of these people have their own
drivers their whole lives in china they
come here
and they they're not drivers they're the
wealthier people so now they have to
drive themselves
and so it's a class issue of where you
end up seeing stereotypically bad
drivers
not to say that it's legitimately true
that you know every person is is bad at
driving but he pointed out
you don't realize these are the wealthy
people who are coming here
and that's why the stereotype you know
ends up coming about i mean in china
people are notoriously bad drivers but
that's also because
they've only been driving since like the
early 2000s really
oh wow most people go yeah bicycles yeah
so
most people had not been driving that
long so
there's a lot of like you know the kind
of traffic adequate that
like the kind of stuff that's not
necessarily a law but like people learn
like you know you're gonna let people
into the lane if they need to like merge
or whatever that stuff doesn't exist
right like that kind of culture because
they haven't been driving them it's it's
pretty easy to just find like horrific
videos of like like someone crossing the
street and then just
like at 100 miles an hour boom run over
by
there's a lot of videos there's a huge
emerging middle class in china which is
looking like it's going to be a problem
for the larger government
it's very interesting to see how they're
going to address that problem but very
interestingly when you talked about the
one
child policy i automatically thought
about many american elites
uh a lot of specialized high level
individuals like ted turner that are
fans
of the one child policy and have
complimented
uh before on the american stage as well
so there it is interesting to see
the kind of ties to a lot of these
individuals i actually talked to ted
turner and i asked him
if you believe in the one child policy
as as you as much as you do and
as much as you advocate for it why do
you have four children
he didn't like that question but well
it's it rules for thee but not for me
of course yeah that's how it is i mean
some animals are more
equal even the one child policy
the is the one child policy was a
failure
absolutely absolutely and the chinese
government kind of
knows it but they can't say it because
they can't admit they made them
yeah so they that's why there's now a
two-child policy instead of a one-child
policy because they realize they screwed
themselves with
the population control and just a big
picture for a moment
the chinese communist party has
concentration camps harvest organs and
for many years it was illegal to have a
brother or a sister wow well yeah there
were some
there were some like this rule
the thing with chinese law or policy is
that like it's a very unevenly
actually it's kind of like they have
like a decree from up top and then like
it's up to the local
officials to implement it and they do it
very unevenly depending on where you are
so if you're in like a wealthier area
maybe you just have to pay a fine and
you can afford it
to have another kid uh in the rural
areas like that's
like the more disadvantaged you are like
the more likely that it's gonna be like
you get hauled into a van
or a forced abortion or something like
that because they have to make an
example out of you
and also the terrible thing was that a
lot of these family planning
policies like the one child policy they
were a way for local governments to make
money so if they couldn't find you then
they would make an example
out of you and uh that even like you
know in the 90s a lot of people were
starting to
adopt chinese girls like
right in the u.s and other kids so they
were like oh well girls aren't wanted
so you know there's 30 million more men
right so
that's what i wanted to ask right did
they create this imbalance where there's
not enough women for the men know they
did but also
there was like something that weird that
happened where there became a black
market
for chinese baby girls to sell
to be adopted in the u.s why
because like they would like let's say
you had a second child
and it was a girl and you didn't want to
give the kid up they could take the kid
from you and put in an
orphanage and the local government could
be like this baby was abandoned
and then so you had cases of like
families where like their kid was
literally taken from them
and then you know the adoptive parents
like usually pay
hundreds or maybe a couple of thousand
dollars to the local government for the
adoption
so the local government is making money
off of like stealing kids
and selling them to be adopted so cool
yeah
and sex trafficking is such a huge issue
i know the trump administration uh
uh sanctioned or not sanctioned but like
uh called out china for human
trafficking
but yeah that's that's a big way they're
dealing with this gender imbalance uh
yes uh sex trappings king from
uh from north korea
you know from like yeah our our show
it's got lots of funny humor
it's fun to watch thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you
all next time